TRY IT FOR AS LITTLE
AS $5 A MONTH.
>> Tucker: A POSSIBLE WAR
WITH SYRIA SEEMS LIKE AN
IMPORTANT NEWS TORE BUT IT'S
NOT THE IMPORTANT NEWS STORY
OF THE DAY.
NOT THE MOST IMPORTANT.
CNN REVEALED THEIR VIEW OF
THAT THIS AFTERNOON.
WHEN THEY CUT AWAY FROM
NIKKI HALEY AT THE U.N. TO
THIS.
>> WE MUST NOT OVERLOOK
RUSSIA AND IRAN'S ROLES IN
ENABLING THE ASSAD REGIME'S
MURDEROUS DESTRUCTION.
RUSSIA AND IRAN HAVE
MILITARY ♪
>> WE'RE GOING TO BRAKE AWAY
FROM NIKKI HALEY'S TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE U.N. SECURITY
COUNCIL.
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS JUST
IN.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" JUST
REPORTED THAT THE FBI TODAY
RAIDED THE OFFICES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LONG-TIME
ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT RAID
REPORTED SOLID CONNECTED TO
THE STORMY DANIELS STORY.
CNN COVERED WALL-TO-WALL AND
OF COURSE STORMY DISANELS
WAY MORE IMPORTANT THAN ANY
WAR WITH SYRIA.
THAT'S CNN'S POSITION.
IS IT MARK STEYN'S POSITION
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK, THE PRIORITIES BECOME
REALLY CLEAR.
YOU CUT FROM THE U.N. WE MAY
GO TO WAR, STORMY DANIELS
NEWS BREAKING.
DID YOU SEE THAT?
>> YEAH.
I SAW THIS NEW FILM
CHAPPAQUIDDICK OVER THE
WEEKEND.
AND AFTER TED KENNEDY HAS
HIS CAR ACCIDENT, HIS DAD,
JOE KENNEDY, CALLS IN ALL
THE OLD KENNEDY FIXES.
AND THEY ARE THRILLED
BECAUSE CHAPPAQUIDDICK
HAPPENED AT THE TIME THAT
MAN WAS ABOUT TO SET FOOT ON
THE MOON.
THEY THOUGHT THIS IS GREAT.
IF MAN SETS FOOT ON THE MOON
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
THIS WILL BURY TED'S CAR
ACCIDENT AND WE'LL BE OKAY.
YOU CAN BET THAT THAT IF MAN
SET FOOT ON THE MOON FOR THE
FIRST TIME AND THEY RAIDED
TRUMP'S LAWYER'S OFFICE,
THAT TRUMP'S LAWYER'S OFFICE
WOULD ABSOLUTELY CRUSH ONE
GIANT STEP FOR MANKIND,
WOULD BURR REQUESTY IT.
IT WOULD BE ON THE FOOT OF
PAGE 37 AND NO ONE WOULD
EVER KNOW MAN HAD LANDED ON
THE MOON.
THAT'S THE PRIORITIES OVER
ON CNN.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE STORMY
DANIELS PICTURES TO
ACCOMPANY IT.
>> AS I SAID TO YOU LAST
TIME IT'S A PERFECTLY GOOD
SEX SCANDAL AND NOW $130,000
CAMPAIGN FINANCE INFRACTION
THAT ROBERT MUELLER AND THE
FBI ARE GOING TO PURSUE TO
THE ENDS OF THE EARTH IN
NECESSARY.
THEY DON'T CARE HOW MANY
DOLLARS THEY SPENT ON
$130,000 CAMPAIGN
INFRACTION.
I LIKE MY SCANDALS TO BE
ABOUT SEX NOT CAMPAIGN
FINANCE.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
WAY LESS APPEALING WHEN 2
BECOMES CAMPAIGN FINANCE.
THE MAYOR OF LONDON KHAN IS
VOWING A CRACK DOWN ON
KNIVES.
CUTTING IMPLEMENTS FOLLOWING
A CRIME WAVE THERE.
THERE IS NEVER A REASON TO
CARRY A KNIFE AND VOWING TO
PUNISH ALL WHO DO.
MEANWHILE IN NEW YORK, IN
RELATED NEWS, BILL DE BLASIO
AIDE REGION AGAIN STEPHENS
ARRESTED AFTER CAUGHT WITH
ILLEGAL HANDGUN IN HER CAR.
WHAT DO THESE ADD UP TO
OTHER THAN LIKE THE END OF
WESTERN CIVILIZATION?
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO ME IN
BRITAIN BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THE NATIONAL CUTLERY
ASSOCIATION HAS COME OUT
STRONGLY AGAINST BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO OWN KNIVES.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE THINKING
THAT, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
OUTLAW KNIVES ONLY OUTLAWS
WILL HAVE KNIVES.
AND I USE THE TERM CUTLERY
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE PEOPLE USE
WHAT'S AT HAPPENED.
I WAS IN A FRENCH VILLAGE,
TWO SUMMERS AGO, AND A LADY
AND TWO OF HER DAUGHTERS
WERE FELT TO BE WERE IN
THEIR BATHING SUITS AND
MOHAMMED NEXT TO THEM WENT
FULL ALLAHU AKBAR AND
STABBED THEM WITH THE FORK.
THE FORK HE WAS HAVING
BREAKFAST WITH AND A
HELICOPTER HAD TO FLY IN AND
HELICOPTER, THE WOUNDED.
PEOPLE USE WHAT'S AT HAND.
THE REALITY IN LONDON AS
KATIE HOPKINS SAID ON YOUR
SHOW A COUPLE OF NIGHTS AGO
IS THAT 85% OF LAST MONTH'S
STABBINGS PERPETRATORS AND
VICTIMS ARE BASICALLY THE
RESULT OF MODERN IMMIGRATION
POLICIES TOO TIE WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT WITH THE
GENERAL ABOUT THE BORDER,
THAT'S THE ISSUE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A BORDER,
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A SECURITY
PERIMETER AT THE BORDER, YOU
WIND UP HAVING TO HAVE
SECURITY PERIMETERS OVER
EVERYTHING ELSE.
INCLUDING.
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
>> CUTLERY DISPLAYS IN
LONDON SUPERMARKETS.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU HAVE A
POPULATION THAT CAN'T
CONTROL ITSELF YOU CAN'T
HAVE RIGHTS IS THE PROBLEM.
>> NO.
>> Tucker: DE BLASIO'S AIDE
GETS CAUGHT WITH ILLEGAL
HANDGUN IS THIS LIKE PETA
RUNNING THE BUTCHER SHOP?
IS THERE ANYTHING MORE
HYPOCRITICAL THAN THIS.
>> BASICALLY THIS IS HIS
ADVISOR ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
MATTERS.
AND SHE IS IN A CAR THAT'S
FILLED WITH MARIJUANA SMOKE
WITH HANDGUN ON WHICH ALL
THE IDENTIFYING MARKS HAVE
BEEN RUBBED OFF.
AND I THINK, AGAIN, THIS
GETS TO A POINT WE COME BACK
TO TIME AND AGAIN,
INCREASINGLY WE LIVE IN A
LAND WHERE THE LAWS DON'T
APPLY TO CERTAIN PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, HE WILL PULL SOME
STRINGS.
SHE'LL SKATE.
AND IF YOU'RE CONNECTED.
IF YOU ARE PART OF A
GOVERNOR'S OR A MAYOR'S
DETAIL, YOU WILL BE FINE.
IF YOU WORK FOR SOMEONE
IMPORTANT, YOU ARE FINE.
AND IF YOU ARE JUST SOME GUY
LIVING IN SOME SUBDIVISION,
YOU DON'T NEED A GUN.
YOU DON'T NEED NOTHING.
AND.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> IT'S THAT DIVISION.
>> Tucker: CLASS SYSTEM.
IT'S AWFUL.